Can I buy the individual components of the clear immutent path? I tried to figure it out, but some are sold by different names. Is there an upcharge for the comedian, so might be cheaper to buy them individually.
I don't know. I've never sat and figured out the math on it.
Yeah, you can use, you know, you can do anything you want. Remember anything I told you nutrition wise, that's what I'm recommending you could do whatever you want. So, you know, if you don't want to take the zinc that I recommend you have the exact same zinc by another brand.
I always take that you have it, I hate to have you waste supplements, but, you know, how I test you is with the supplements that I'm recommending. So, you are, you know, if it's the exact same thing, you're taking.
Make these your Malay by, you know, any company is going to be the same. But if you're taking, you know, a burberry by one company is not going to be the same thing as a burberry by another company.
A lot of supplement companies, especially inexpensive supplements are inexpensive because they're, they're water down about water with powder.
There's, I told you before that there's, there's when studies done where they went to Target and Walmart and it's the vitamin score, I forgot.
And they, a couple of other store where they bought some Ashwagoda and some different or most supplements and they tested them in the one that tested best had like 10% of what was on the lane.
So there's, there's just a lot of, you know, bad stuff out there. There's lots of times there's a reason why some things are less expensive because they're not really what's on the label and they get by because nobody tests them.
So if you're not getting it for a reputable company, you're just taking that chance.